Berry is with us berries in Arlington
Virginia hi Barry how are you
definitely Haven day how you doing
better than I deserve and what is your
net worth sir 1.5 million gotcha
cool and how old are you I'm 48 my life
is 49 all right and what is that
invested in primarily what are the big
chunks of that 1.5 million about 98% of
it's in neutral funds and about 2% of
its and stocks okay so you don't owe me
any houses no we're in the military so
we've free ball houses in the past the
current we live in DC where it's very
expensive so we're currently renting
okay great
and what's your range of income through
your working lifetime range of income
probably starting about 30k actually
follow that 50k between the two of us
and we're right now we're just over two
hours okay
well excellent very cool and how much is
the 1.5 million did you inherit zero
okay how much of it did you steal from
somebody because you know the rumor
isn't all rich people are crooks right
I've heard the rumor but don't believe
what you hear okay so what's your degree
in I have a undergrad in business
administration also have an MBA okay
cool
and what was your GPA GPA undergrad
wasn't wasn't that great probably about
2.7 and my Master's was 3.8 okay all
right cool and how much of the 1.5
million is there because you borrowed
money to make money with it
zero okay cool what part is giving
played in your working life citroen
military we we support a few
organizations veterans tickets
foundation they provide tickets to
military service men and women for sport
events plays etc we also support team
red white and blue that provides social
events and social events for voluntary
and also we supports USO not you okay
cool which branch do servants
air force and what's your rank
lieutenant Carl awesome way to go very
cool what's the most expensive pair of
jeans you ever bought probably $35 all
right cool how many brand new cars did
you buy before you had a million dollar
net worth we've had two new cars but we
both cars we've had for 10 plus years
and right now I'm Domino 400 core with
about $110,000 okay only nonfiction
books do you read here probably about a
dozen okay cool what's the best one
you've read not counting Dave Ramsey
books in the past two years probably
recently read the famous Stuart story
and I'm reading me a book about Thalia
Dungey oh really
very cool I've a buddy of mine wrote the
Payne Stewart story that Ken Abraham
wrote that yeah okay it's a good book
it's a really good book yeah and I was
it was a good man it was an interesting
so as a weird weird death but an
interesting thing his wife's evidently
really nice people yes sir very cool
good stuff man so what is your advice to
the younger version of you that's
listening to this right now the
20-something version of you out there
walking around can you still start in
America today and end up with a million
five you definitely can and this
probably for us is three things at work
we uh number ones dollar cost average
and you need to fund every month
probably the most important is live
below your means and number three is
system in the military I'm able to
contribute through the throw statement
around yep so we maxed out out over here
and we also max out I raised over here
you do that for twenty thirty years
come on OSU very chance well thank you
for your service to the country and
economically you're a hero as well a
million five in net worth of forty eight
years olds no slouch way to go dude you
killed it I'm proud of you
thank you for calling in and sharing
your life with us and telling us it can
be done this is a millionaire theme our
on the Dave Ramsey shadow hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
you can do this you know that really is
a message whether you've got two hundred
seventy thousand dollars in student loan
debt or twenty seven thousand well
you've got a fifty thousand dollar
income a five hundred thousand dollar
income